let's get some perspective now and
inside of the stories we brought you
before the break the North Korea hostage
settlement and what comes next the Iran
deal and other stories senior political
analyst Brit Hume joins us tonight in
studio good to have you back in DC
thanks good your thoughts on you know
this is a big development obviously with
these three Americans landing tonight or
earlier this morning but in these
setting the table for what the president
hopes will be something bigger indeed
and you know that you got the president
now being confronted with questions
about whether he's likely candidate for
the Nobel Prize and and to some extent
at least he's he's pushed back against
that idea but I think you know he really
does obviously hope that this is going
to turn into a kind of an agreement a
credible enforceable verifiable
agreement on nuclear on the
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
which would be a huge achievement now
make no mistake about it so this thing
that happened today the return of these
hostages is important in the sense that
it wasn't very many months ago Brett
when people were saying that by his
saber rattling and bellicose attitude
Donald Trump was bringing it to the
brink of war in the Korean Peninsula he
heard it a lot we heard it a lot and and
look where we are now it has had
obviously the opposite effect that
doesn't mean that you know we're headed
for the land of Hope and Glory over
there but but it is a significant
achievement to get this far but
obviously you know a lot of remains to
be seen on the other big nuclear issue
on Iran it seems like the Europeans are
trying to talk to Iran separate of the
u.s. pulling out of this deal that
doesn't seem to be like a realistic
prospect does it it doesn't at the
moment but the big question here the the
key question is how much difference to
Iran will the realization of American
sanctions make now the American banking
system is central to the whole world
economy you don't want to be shut out of
it our allies don't want to run afoul of
that as either so there are reasons why
we might hope that the realization of
American sanctions will make a
difference to Iran and to our allies as
to whether they will join us in trying
to pressure Iran
to making a separate or different deal
you know it's we can't tell now and a
lot of people you know you hear the
people from the Obama administration
saying this is a disaster that now all
the shackles are off and Iran will
sprint toward a nuclear weapon I'm not
sure they'll do that but I think you
know the the policy of being tough and
strong and wielding sanctions has shown
in North Korea that it can work and it
may now show that it can work with Iran
as well all this pushback that America
is is telling the world that it doesn't
live up to its commitments one
administration to annex the response
from supporters of this move say well
the President Obama could have made it a
treaty well he could have been of course
the reason he didn't obviously it was he
knew that he couldn't pay that this deal
couldn't pass the Senate I mean couldn't
it probably couldn't even gotten a
majority in the Senate which is because
the deal is problematic from the jump
and so the Kratt spoke out a lot of
Democrat a Democrat spoke out against it
and a lot of them are now calling about
what he's doing were bitching about the
deal back then so you know there's a lot
of shoe on the other foot stuff going on
here Brett which is a disease in
Washington you know yeah very quickly
the Gina hospital testimony today and
the hearing it seems like she has a lot
of support inside the intelligence
community clearly but there is a split
along party lines and the questioning it
was is there ever and what I would say
about it is it looks as if she hasn't
lost any Republicans if she did she'd be
she might be she might go down she
picked up one Democrat today but one
Democrat can make all the difference in
the world subtracts one from the groups
of voting against her and adds one to
those who will it means that if John
McCain doesn't come back then
Republicans are down to a fifty one vote
they lose Rand Paul they're at 50 joe
manchin all other things being equal on
everybody voting along party lines would
give him give her a majority so I think
you know on balance tonight it looks
good for her and you know Brett this
really is a case where the complaints
about her of retroactively morality you
know she got she got kind of stumped by
the question from common law Harris who
asked her you know do you think that the
enhanced interrogation techniques were
immoral
right well by the standards of that day
and time and and by the ruling by the
Justice Department the answer has got to
be no she didn't want to say that but of
course by today's standards now under
that what everybody's now on their high
horse about this the answer is that it
would be immoral so that's where we are
retroactive morality all the way around
beretta it's always great to have you
here thanks Brett